bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france donc une minute
de silence a été observée aujourd'hui au
royaume uni pour les un an du
confinement dans quel état d'esprit sont
les britanniques aujourd'hui justement
si on appelle la minute de silence c'est
parce que c'est un pays un peu en deuil
et cette minute de silence a été appelée
à pas du tout par à boston ce n'est pas
une oeuvre de charité
mike curie qui s'occupe des gens en fin
de vie
soutenu par le prince charles donc c'est
c'est la nation a en quelque sorte qui
fait le 2e et deux parce que je pense
qu'il 120 mille morts
et donc c'est vrai qu'elle est la
compagne de vaccin est un énorme succès
et que les hôpitaux et les centres de
vaccination vraiment assuré mais le
gouvernement aimerait bien fait oublier
à cause de pas ce succès là le fait que
derrière il y as et ça a été terrible
pour les anglais seuls les consignes au
début c'était du genre à porter un
masque si ça ne vous dérange pas trop
peut-être c'est mieux de faire du
télétravail si c'est possible
et après là le gouvernement a dépensé
mais des milliards pour une ap de
traçage des cas qui n'a absolument pas
marché il ya eu plein de scandale y
compris un ministre qui donnait des
contrats pour fournir les masques et
tout ça à des amis à lui et du
gouvernement donc dit oui mais quand
même on a eu ce succès avec notre vaccin
mais maintenant c'est le pays qui fait
une minute de silence à midi
et puis ce soit fait un vigile ou toul à
tout le monde est censé aller devant
chez soi avec une bougie ou une lampe
pour profane sorte de commémoration de
tous les morts donc c'est c'est un juste
un peu contre en quelque sorte contre
bochum alors contre boris johnson cela
alors que le royaume uni a tout de même
mené une campagne de vaccination massive
qui est toujours en courant puisqu'il
s'est presque 26 millions de
britanniques qui ont été vaccinés ça
c'est plutôt à un succès
oui c'est un énorme succès le
l'angleterre a bien vu qu'il fallait
tout de suite acheté des doses il était
pas mal premier acheter les doses
après l'angleterre n'a pas attendu la
fin des études à pour commencer la
campagne de vaccins ils ont été
critiqués quand même j'ai des amis en
angleterre acquis qui avait pas parce
qu'ils avaient reçu la première dose et
personne ne leur disais quand il est
allé à voir leur deuxième dose est un
peu inquiet parce que pour les anglais
en fait il faut absolument vacciner le
plus possible parce que boris johnson
parle d'une troisième vague qui vient
intérêts de l'europe mais ça vient aussi
de l'intérieur de l'angleterre parce
qu'il ya plein de gens qui ne respectent
pas les consignes la dernière fois que
j'étais à londres
on voyait des masques dans le centre de
londres
mais en dehors dans les rues a envoyé
pas des masques je suis sortie m'a
baladé et une fois je me suis retournée
aller chez moi parce que il y avait un
flot de gens ce qu'ils venaient vers moi
si le roi sans masque donc il faut
absolument vacciner le plus vite
possible et c'est la preuve c'est que ça
marche les maintenant enfin les cas les
morts diminue en angleterre donc ce avec
elle la vaccination c'est un énorme
succès et les anglais sont un peu fier
parce que notre système de santé
britannique
gratuit et tout ça c'est un peu la
fierté de la nation et là ils ont
vraiment assumé alors vous avez vous des
amis en lui et moi j'ai eu des proches
aussi au royaume uni hier en tout cas ce
qu'ils semblent régner c'est la
confiance vis-à-vis de cette campagne de
vaccination
là encore comment l'expliquer parce
qu'on voit comme par exemple en france
il ya une certaine défiance notamment
vis-à-vis du vaccin astrazeneca pour
récemment oui les gens en confiance en
ce vaccin qui a été développé à oxyde
c'était mon université mais c'est une
coïncidence mais en général les études
faites à oxted sont assez bien fait
nous les enlever en confiance en ce
vaccin et surtout c'est le grand espoir
il faut absolument se faire vacciner
et puis il ya aussi une sorte de guerre
politique entre l'europe et l'angleterre
sur ce vaccin
est ce qu'il est bien est ce qu'il faut
faire tourner à l'angleterre il ya une
bataille pour les deux entre
l'angleterre et l'union européenne donc
c'est devenu très politique donc je
pense que les anglais on dit juste
boilard ya un vaccin on va le prendre et
c'est vrai que ça marche on voit les cas
a diminué donc des anglais en sauté sur
l'occasion de s' était un espoir il faut
les anglais sont assez optimistes et qui
est un espoir
on y croit on y va et c'est une autre
côté un peu optimiste voilà alors vous
disiez bord et d'une salle qui est un
peu sous le feu des critiques au début
de cette pandémie aujourd'hui l'essai
s'est lui-même vacciné là aussi une
première injection du vaccin fort
d'astrazeneca
il est en reconquête est-ce qu'il va
surfer sur le succès justement de cette
campagne de vaccination au niveau
politique c'est ça qu'ils espèrent ils
il espère vraiment que l'on n'oublie les
tous les problèmes qu'il ya eu derrière
120000 man le plus grand tour de
l'europe
il va être qu'ils la fassent oublier ça
il lance même une campagne pour un
annonçant qu' on va acheter des missiles
nucléaires ibor il va retransformer ce
petit pays en grande nation nucléaire
sur la planète
ce que beaucoup d'anglais trouve absurde
donc oui il veut surfer sur cette vague
et la chance qu'il a c'est comme un
seigneur l'angleterre l'opposition est
complètement silencieuse n'ya pas il ya
personne en face de lui donc il opère
tout seul il gère très bien les médias
et les très médiatiques qui parle hyper
bien donc il a la liberté de surfer sur
ce grand succès qui est la compagne de
vaccination
merci beaucoup à vous stéphane clarke
écrivain merci d'avoir répondu en direct
à nos questions sur rt france